So the answer is, we only need to add one line.
We need to add the line at line 13. And the
line that we need, is to update the graph. So we're
going to have a new entry in the graph, that is the page
that we're crawling. So that's going to be the key for the
entry that we want to associate with that page, a list of
the links. That you can reach from that page, all the
outgoing links. Well that's exactly what we stored in the variable outlinks.
So that's the only line of code that we need to
add, to produce the graph. We needed to initialize the graph
as an empty dictionary, we needed to change the return it.
But the only substantive change, was adding this line. And, we'll run
that, we'll call crawl_web. Passing in the test URL. And this
time we have two variables on the left side. So we're
going to assign the index to index. And we'll assign the graph
to graph. And let's check that the graph has what it should.
So we'll print out to get graph entry for the index page. And, what we get, we
see a list of five URLs. Hummus, arsenic, kathleen. Nickel and zinc. And this
corresponds to the picture here. We had
five outgoing links from the index page to
those five other pages. Let's look at another
one. We can print the graph for the
Kathleen page, and that had no outgoing links, so what we
see here is the empty list. And, we can see the
whole graph, we have each URL. With a list of all
the pages that, that page links to. So both the Hummus and
the Kathleen page don't link to anything. The Zinc page links
to the Nickel page, and the Arsenic page, and so on.
So now we have our graph. The next step is to
figure out how to use that graph, to do the page ranks.